das war's mit 2016 das jahr geht zu ende
und wir werfen einen blick zurück auf
die fünf wichtigsten errungenschaften
und meldungen aus der welt der
wissenschaft los gehts herzlich
willkommen so klicks um science and
fiction auf der 5 die beste nachricht
des jahres das jahr hat mit einer
erfreulichen nachricht begonnen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation who hat
die ebola epidemie im januar 2016 für
beendet erklärt dabei sah das ganze
zuvor noch anders aus noch im dezember
2015 hatte bunnys
die gesundheitsministerin von liberia
folgendes gesagt zitat der kampf gegen
ebola ist nicht vorbei aber wir dürfen
die hoffnung nicht verlieren zitat ende
einige zeit zuvor waren ein zehnjähriger
junge sein vater und einer seiner
geschwister in liberia nahe der
hauptstadt monrovia an ebola erkrankt
weil dollar im jahr 2014 aus pracht
starben geschätzt knapp mehr als 11.000
300 menschen an den folgen der infektion
und rund 28.600 menschen wurden
infiziert
die dunkelziffer soll allerdings viel
höher liegen in guinea dem land in dem
das virus zuerst ausbrach konnte im
januar 2016 aber ein großer erfolg herum
werden es waren 42 tage ohne
neuinfektion vergangen erreicht ein land
dieses ziel gilt es als ebola frei auch
wenn die whu die ebola epidemie als
beendet erklärt hat muss weiterhin
wachsamkeit gelten
die vier sensationelles zur kernfusion
auch in der physik begann es schon früh
im jahr zu brodeln und zwar fast
wortwörtlich in der fusionsanlage
wendelstein 7-x die forscher des
max-planck-instituts für plasmaphysik
kurz die pp hatten in einer vakuumkammer
zehn milligramm helium für rund eine
zehntelsekunde auf eine temperatur von
rund einer million grad celsius gebracht
dadurch war ein extrem heißes und
dichtes helium plasma entstanden mit
diesem plasma könnte man in zukunft auf
der erde eine kleine künstliche sonne
betreiben bei diesen temperaturen kommt
es zu einer kernfusion zwei atomkerne
verschmelzen hier zu einem neuen kern
auf der sonne da draußen im all
passiert das die ganze zeit bei 15
millionen grad celsius und dabei wird
sehr viel energie freigesetzt im
gegensatz zur sonne konnten die forscher
im dezember 2015 nur ein helium plasma
erzeugen um tatsächlich eine künstliche
sonne betreiben zu können braucht man
wasserstoff plasma und das wurde im
februar in die realität umgesetzt
das erzeugen von wasserstoff plasma
schien damals eigentlich noch in weiter
ferne zu liegen den experten des max
planck instituts für plasmaforschung ist
aber unmöglich erscheint es gelungen bei
einem versuch im februar war es ihnen
innerhalb einer halben stunde nach
versuchs start gelungen
sie hatten wasserstoff plasma erzeugt
auf der drei eine bahnbrechende
erfindung ist das speichermedium der
zukunft nicht die cloud etwa sondern ein
stückchen glas so sieht es scheinbar aus
experten des mercedes optical research
centers der universität southampton
haben im jahr 2016 ein speichermedium
entwickelt dass es nicht nur möglich
macht eine gewaltige menge an daten zu
speichern sondern diese auch noch nach
mehreren und jetzt kommt's milliarden
jahren
abrufbar sind das klingt jetzt ein wenig
seltsam da wir ja da alle nicht mehr in
der lage sein werden diese daten zu
verwenden aber für zukünftige
generationen könnte diese speicher form
interessant sein zitat diese technologie
sichert den letzten beweis unserer
zivilisation alles was wir gelernt haben
wird niemals vergessen werden so
professor peter kazan ski vom rc auf der
glasscheibe die etwas größer als ein
daumen ist können 360 terabyte über eine
zeit von fast 14 milliarden jahren
gespeichert werden und das funktioniert
so mit einem femtosekundenlaser werden
auf der glasplatte winzig kleine punkte
in fünf schichten eingebrannt die
abstände der punkte liegen dabei im
mikrometerbereich das gerät gibt sehr
kurze laserimpulse ab eine femtosekunde
dauern diese an das sind 10 hoch minus
15 sekunden daher auch der name des
lesers je nachdem wie die punkte
eingebrannt werden ergibt sich dann eine
andere lichtbrechung damit auch eine
andere information der datenträger wird
als 5 disc bezeichnet da die daten auf
fünf ebenen geschrieben und ausgelesen
werden
das lässt am ehesten sich vergleichen
mit anderen optischen datenträgern zum
beispiel mit der cd hier werden durch
einen laser lens und pitts in den
datenträger gebrannt die später aus
gelehrten lesen werden können
das prinzip hier war ist dann allerdings
als 2d zu bezeichnen unter den
dokumenten die jetzt wohl fast 14
milliarden jahre lang haltbar sind
befinden sich derzeit schon das werk
optics von isaac newton die king james
bibel und die declaration of human
rights also die erklärung der
menschenrechte ein wenig erinnern die
glasscheiben an die superman memory
crystals aus dem film superman
eine wichtige erkenntnis gibt es auf
platz zwei so viele gene braucht es für
leben 2016 ist es forschern gelungen
die exakte zahl der lebewesen gehende zu
bestimmen um es direkt vorweg zu nehmen
473 gene braucht man den amerikanischen
forschern zufolge um ein lebewesen zu
kreieren das haben sie dieses jahr im
fachmagazin science publiziert die
mindestzahl von 473 gehen reicht
allerdings gerade mal für ein bakterium
ein mensch besitzt rund 23.000 gene die
forscher klatschen sind tree und ray
young vom craig venter institute kurz
gcv erzeugen künstlich mit ihren
kollegen das bakterium sind 1.0
das war 2010 institutsleiter krieg
center ist übrigens derjenige der die
menschliche dna zum ersten mal komplett
sequenziert hat also das menschliche
erbgut analysiert hat das bakterium sind
1.0 dient den weiteren studien dann als
testobjekt sie die aktivierten immer
weitere gene um beobachten zu können
welche teile davon tatsächlich gebraucht
werden am ende sind 473 gene übrig
geblieben sie hatten das künstliche
bakterium sind 3.0 erschaffen
unter laborbedingungen konnte das
bakterium so überleben
die forscher gehen allerdings davon aus
dass für ein überleben ohne diese
bedingung mehr gene nötig werden bei
ihren untersuchungen stießen die
forscher auch auf 149 gene die sie nicht
identifizieren konnten wir wurden durch
den versuch auch neue forschungsansätze
geschaffen
das größte highlight des jahres das
findet natürlich auch die nummer 1
wieder die von albert einstein
vorhergesagten gravitationswellen wurden
tatsächlich entdeckt es war einer der
letzten beweise für die
relativitätstheorie und eine sensation
und einstein durchlaufen diese wellen
raum und zeit wenn ein kosmisches
großereignis geschieht durch das die
gravitation von riesigen himmelskörpern
verändert wird würden zum beispiel zwei
schwarze löcher kollidieren müssten
solche gravitationswellen durch das
weltall jagen und den raum kommen anfang
des jahres gab es hinweise darauf dass
am international wave observatorio kurz
lego veränderung gemessen würden die die
existenz von gravitationswellen
bestätigen würden
ja und was man dann dort gemessen hat
sind tatsächlich gravitationswellen die
durch die kollision von zwei schwarzen
löchern entstanden sind kurz vor dem
zusammenstoß kreisten sie mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 4.500 umdrehungen
pro minute um einander die kollision
geschah dann in sekundenbruchteilen und
war dann auch ziemlich schnell vorbei am
11 februar 2016 wurde
dieser fund der gravitationswellen
tatsächlich offiziell bestätigt wahnsinn
was waren für euch die
wissenschaftlichen highlights des jahres
2016 durchforstet mal unsere videos und
kreiert euer eigenes ranking unter
diesem video in den kommentaren das
beliebteste reingehen werden wir dann
als video umsetzen wenn euch dieses
video gefallen hat dann lasst uns gerne
natürlich genau dem da einen daumen nach
oben und ein kostenloses abo da dafür
einfach hier klicken und wenn ihr hier
klickt genau da da kommt ihr zur best of
tricks und playlist mit den allerbesten
themen und videos hier bei pixum
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran